ينضم الينا من جدا الدكتور عبد العزيز بن
صقر رئيسه مركز الخليج للابحاث الدكتور
عبد العزيز مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض جمله من الاحداث السياسيه هذا
العام في همم السعوديه والخليج السعوديه
بدورها جماعه الخليج والعرب في طاولتين مع
قطبي النظام الدولي امريكا والصين في 2022
ما الذي تحقق منها هل اختارت السعوديه
الجنوح مع احد القطبي
اول مساء الخير لك استاذ نايف ولكل
مشاهدين العربيه في كل مكان ونتمنى ان
يكون عام 2023 عام خير وبركه اسود فيه
الامن والسلامه والازدهار للشعوب العالم
الحقيقه زياره القاده المهمين سواء الرئيس
الامريكي في قمه جده والرئيس الصيني في
قمه الرياضه والزعماء الذين توادوا عن
المملكه خلال عام 2022 هو تاكيد لدور
المملكه الاساسي
ودورها القيادي في المنطقه ليس فقط على
مستوى اهميه العلاقه الثنائيه مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ولكن دور المملكه
القيادي فيما في منظومه دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وايضا في المنظومه العربيه والشرق
الاوسطيه وايضا حكم عضيتها في مجموعه
العشرين الدوليه فهذا تاكيد على اهميه
المملكه ودورها التوقيت جاء بعد مجموعه من
القضايا يعني ما كنا نخرج من ازمه همم
يعني كورونا والجائحه
2021 حتى بدانا عام 22 بالازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وعوده الى مفهوم الحرب البارده
وارتفاع في اسعار النفط
ومجموعه القضايا هذه القلمتين التي حدثت
جاءت لتؤكد ان السعوديه تفهم وتعي
مسؤوليتها الاقليميه والدوليه تعي اهميه
هذه العلاقه بنسبه لها مع القطبين الكبيره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمال المملكه
لها من علاقه تاريخيه قديمه
جدا هي لا ترى ان احد منهم بديلا للاخر
ولذلك حافظت على علاقه متوازنه مع كافه
الاطراف حافظت على علاقات المتوازنه
والمهمه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
محافظه ايضا على علاقه الاقتصاديه القويه
مع الصين طيب دكتور تخفيض انت همم
قبل نوفمبر كان قرارا اقتصاد وشغل السياسه
كذلك كان قرارا بحثا كما قالت مجموعه اوبك
بلس في مقدماتها طبعا السعوديه لكن هو اخذ
ابعد سياسيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما تعلم التي اعتبرته عدائيا
اعتبرته كذلك احيازا لروسيا كيف تنظر
لنتائجه السياسيه حتى الان والتعامل
السعودي مع هذا الموقع
المملكه قررت ان تتعامل من منطلق مصالحها
وقرار اوبك بلس وكان قرار منطلقه توافقي
وفني بحث ولذلك ادعي الكثير انه سوف يؤثر
على الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلى وضع
الانتخابات ولكنه لم يؤثر والدليل انه بعد
قرار اوبلاس انخفضت اسعار النفط ولم ترتفع
فلم يؤثر هذا على وضع الانتخابات الداخليه
ورفضت المملكه ان يستخدم موضوع اوبلاس
كذريعه وحجه في قضايا انتخابيه داخليه
للولايات المتحده ال- الامريكيون يقررون
من يختارون من الاحزاب التي يريدون لها
غالبيه في الكونجرس او في الحكم وهذا قرار
داخلي امريكي فلذلك لم تتاثر المملكه
بالضغوط الامريكيه والرغبات التي كانت
موجوده
حافظت على قرارها
واكدت على سيادتها في ما يتعلق بهذا
القرار وكان قرارا جماعيا توافقيا بين كل
الاطراف
ناتج عنه النتيجه الايجابيه التي نراها ان
المملكه استطاعت ترسل رساله للعالم لم نعد
تلك الدوله التي تقبل الاملاءات ولكن
الدوله ذات سياده نتعامل من منطلق مصالحنا
ومصالح الدول التي لها يعني مصالح معنى
مهمه دون ان نخضع لاي ضغوط ايا كانت من
منطلق المصالح همم الدكتور ايضا ال-
الموقف الخليجي الموقف السعودي ايضا
تحديدا في الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه بقيه
موقفا على همم الحياه لم ياخذ او لم يجنح
الى احد طرفي همم النزاع برايك هذا موقف
ثابت
هو موقف متوازن وليس موقف حياتي التوازن
في اننا نعي ثوابت ثوابت ان اوكرانيا دوله
عضو في الامم المتحده لا يمكن ان نقبل ان
يتم احتلالها بالقوه واستخدام القوه وزير
خارجيه السعودي اكد على وحده اوكرانيا
وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه نعي تماما اهميه
ان يسود الامن والسلامه هذه قضيه اوروبيه
في منطقتهم علاقتنا مع روسيا لم تتاثر لان
هذا هذا خلاف فيما بين دولتين يحل داخل
الامم المتحده ويحل واكدنا على قضيه البعد
السلمي في الحلول والسياسي ساهمنا في
ساهمت المملكه في موضوع اطلاق سراح
الرهائن في البعد الانساني قدمت مساعدات
انسانيه مهمه لاوكرانيا بقدر ما هو مطلوب
لكنه لم تتدخل من اي نقطه هي لان ترفض
المملكه العوده الى مفهوم الحرب البارده
الذي اراد البعض ان يعود اليه
كانت محورا على موقف توازن ممكن متوازن
مهم وهذا الموقف المتوازي المهم مثلنا مثل
دوله زي الهند وزي تركيا بالرغم ان تركيا
عضو في حلف الناتو ولكن ايضا هم حافظوا
على التوازن قدمت المملكه ما تستطيع ان
تقدم في هذا الجانب لانه يعني ابقت ولذلك
هذه النقطه التي يقول انها حافظت المملكه
على تواجد تندفع للجانب الامريكي في قبول
الضغط على روسيا او باي مساهمات هي ابقت
العلاقه جيده مع روسيا هي لم تقبل احتلال
الارض بالقوه والصراع الذي يحدث في
اوكرانيا وقدمت المساعدات الانسانيه همم
فاستطاعت ان توجد هذه التوازنيه في
العلاقات والتي لم تكون في السابق موجوده
بهذا الشكل طيب دكتور عديد الزعماء كانت
السعوديه قبله لهم في همم الايام الماضيه
خلال هذا العام والتقى تحديدا ولي العهد
السعودي رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان اسال عن دور القيادي الثقل السياسي
لهذه الشخصيه في هذا العام دكتور
هو اعتراف بدور المملكه القيادي هو اعتراف
بدور سمو ولي عهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
وقيادته الحكيمه هو ايضا اعتراف باهميه
المملكه ولذلك حينما تكون زيارات شخصيه
فهذه الدول لها متطلبات ولها طلبات تريد
باللقاء الشخصي ان تقدم طلباتهم مباشره
المملكه وان تحاول الحصول على بعض
التنازلات نحن راينا ذلك حين ما زار
المستشار الالماني او بعض الرؤساء الذين
زاروا من دون مختلفه مثل الجنوب افريقيا
وخلافه ولكن المملكه دائما كعاملتنا منطلق
مصالحها الاساسيه والوطنيه التي يجب ان
تسود في كل الحالات قد تقدر هذه العلاقات
الثنائيه وتهتم بها ولها مكانات وتقديرها
ولكن هذا اعتراف دولي من كل القيادات
العالميه بان الدور هو دور المملكه هي
الدوله المؤثره خليجيا وعربيا وشرق
اوساطيا واذا اقتنعت المملكه بالموقف
السياسي تستطيع ان تقنع الاخرين بهذا
الموقف من جد الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس مركز ابحاث الخليج اللامحات شكرا
جزيلا لك